[Musica]
potrei avere un bicchiere d'acqua per
favore
[Applauso]
bere un bicchiere d'acqua e qualcosa di
semplice che gesto semplice che gesto
usuale qui da noi
dall'altra parte del mondo non c'è
niente di usuale niente di semplice è
una conquista quasi circa dieci anni fa
ho perso mio figlio andrea
lui era andato in oratorio per una
partita di pallone
alle tre del pomeriggio e alle se non
c'era già più
non è mai più tornato a casa
in quei momenti terribili di dolore
scarnificante di dolore che faccio
ancora fatica quasi dopo dieci anni a
riportare la memoria che devo a dio solo
una cosa di darmi la forza di darmi un
motivo per rimanere ancora su questa
terra
e così ripensai ad alcuni viaggi che
facevo in etiopia alcuni viaggi che
avevamo fatto da turisti da semplici
turisti con la nostra famiglia ripensai
alle sue parole che mi avevano tanto
colpito perché lui da ragazzino era
rimasto molto colpito da ragazzini come
lui che non avevano acqua o che si
abbeveravano addirittura d'acqua sporca
d'acqua e sana ad acqua di pozzanghere
ripensa e le sue parole poi
nel tentativo di aggrapparmi a qualcosa
forse sapendo consapevolmente che
qualcosa avrei trovato andrai andare a
frugare fra le sue cose e lì trovai dei
segnali precisi dei segnali evidenti
lui aveva scritto questa sua questo suo
desiderio che aveva espresso anche a
parole aveva anche disegnato e lì fu la
mia illuminazione io in quel momento
stavo ricevendo un segnale forte la
strada era chiarissima lui me la stava
indicando io dovevo soltanto percorrerla
e da lì nacque il progetto che tuttora
si chiama un pozzo per andrea un pozzo
per andrea semplicemente perché nella
mia nella mia intenzione c'era quello di
realizzare il suo desiderio quindi un
pozzo di acqua potabile
in realtà come dico sempre il male si
può fermare vedete perché i criminali
possono essere messi in carcere
le guerre prima o poi per quanto
doloroso finiscono le malattie si
possono curare il bene invece no il bene
una volta innescato produce una reazione
a catena tesa all'infinito e quindi da
quel progetto che si chiama tuttora
ripeto un posto per andrea questa catena
e continuata ha continuato a generare
amore a generare acqua a germogliare
vita a far germogliare vita e in questo
momento ci sono in etiopia 30 pozzi di
acqua potabile profonda che donano ogni
giorno per sempre e che doneranno acqua
fin dopo anche la mia stessa morte la
nostra stessa morte
io mi reco con le persone che mi danno
una mano
ogni anno in quelle terre anche più
volte all'anno adesso caso del covip
non posso andare tutto il lock down ma
ci andrò presto perché sono pronti gli
ultimi cinque pozzi e miracoli e vedete
nella zai precedente avete messo un
bambino che si abbeverava io queste cose
le ho visto coi miei occhi lo
fotografate con il mio cellulare e ogni
volta
vedete io chiedo a dio perdono perché io
mi lamento tuttora mi lamento della mia
vita
chiedo a lui perdono perché io vedo
queste cose e non le posso mai più
scordare andrea andrea continua a vivere
vivrà per sempre perché perché l'amore
non può finire l'amore continua cosa
dirvi portare acqua a quelle popolazioni
rurali a quelle popolazioni massacrate
da siccità e carestia significa
inevitabilmente portare vita vedete il
corpo umano è formato al 70 per cento di
acqua
pensate soltanto un uomo un essere umano
può sopravvivere anche un mese senza
mangiare ma solo dopo 48 ore che non
beve
l'essere umano muore senza acqua
veramente non c'è vita e questo è un
bene primario
che purtroppo in questo momento è un
privilegio di pochi e non un diritto di
tutti questo lo sperimento mi dà dolore
mi dà mi fa riflettere ogni giorno
portare a quelli partecipare alla festa
alla gioia di questi di queste
popolazioni che per la prima volta hanno
una fonte di acqua potabile è qualcosa
che io non riesco a spiegare con le
parole veramente non riesco è una gioia
infinita persone che ti ringraziano
chiti veramente titti si aggrappano non
sanno più cosa fare per ringraziarti io
mi sento piccola così questa cosa mi dà
invece di mi mette in imbarazzo
terribile perché perché quello loro
diritto non è noi non stiamo facendo
altro che cercare di alleviare le loro
sofferenze ma le loro sofferenze sono
sono pazzesche pensate che se bevendo da
fonti di acqua da fiumi insalubri
d'acqua e salubre ed acqua inquinata i
bambini per l'ottanta per cento non
arrivano ai 5 anni e non sopravvivono
perché per infezioni intestinali per
virus per malattie
di tutti i generi e questo è terribile
credetemi per idea
comunque la riflessione che volevo
lasciarmi questa sera è proprio questa
che cosa possiamo fare noi da questa
parte del mondo per per contribuire ad
alleviare la mancanza d'acqua che prima
o poi vedete acqua non vuol dire
soltanto bere acqua vuol dire anche
igiene pensiamo adesso in questo momento
parti con questo momento storico
particolare che importanza all igiene
per esempio coal co lead lo sappiamo
tutti
e poi un'altra altra riflessione
noi spesso pensiamo che le cose che
succedono è che cadono dall'altra parte
del mondo non ci toccheranno io per
prima quando ho sentito parlare di co
lead e parlo quindi di una cosa
estremamente attuale che ci tocca tutti
io per prima avevo sentito di questa
malattia dall'altra parte del mondo in
cina si coronavirus non sapevo neanche
poi in un batter in un batter d'occhio
questo o questo ci ha coinvolti
totalmente ci ha segnati totalmente ci
segna totalmente quindi non dobbiamo mai
pensare che ciò che accade nella
dall'altra parte del mondo non debba
accadere noi a noi cosa possiamo fare
possiamo fare tante possiamo avere tanti
piccoli accorgimenti nella nostra vita
quotidiana che ci possano che possano
contribuire a non consumare acqua e per
esempio ridurre gli sprechi
pensate soltanto quando ci laviamo i
denti una cosa che facevo anch'io
obiettivamente noi ci laviamo i denti
più delle volte lasciamo il rubinetto
aperto sono decine di litri d'acqua
se non solo lo chiudessimo quelli three
d'acqua sarebbero risparmiati
scegliere ridurre gli sprechi per
esempio quindi ridurre questo è questo
esempio è calzante facciamo la doccia
consumiamo intanto che ci insaponiamo
che ci laviamo sono decine di altre
decine e decine di litri d'acqua
possiamo anche riparare le perdite per
esempio dalle condutture una conduttura
che perde goccia a goccia sono centinaia
di litri d'acqua e poi regolare consumi
quindi magari scegliere dei cud e cicli
economici per la nostra lavatrice per la
nostra lavastoviglie tante piccole
accortezze che fanno la differenza che
possono fare la differenza
io
[Musica]
oltre a questo messaggio che mi sento di
lasciare stasera volevo lasciarvi con
molta aumentano un altro un altro
messaggio che per me è fondamentale
vedete quando si sperimenta un dolore
come quello e la vita purtroppo non è
mai tutti quanti abbiamo i nostri dolori
chi più chi meno i gravissimi chi gravi
quando si sperimenta un dolore come
quello che ho dovuto subire io non
bisogna chiudersi c'è sempre una mano
tesa
bisogna cercare un motivo bisogna
bisogna sempre pensare io ci ho creduto
fin dall'inizio che in fondo quel tunnel
c'è sempre una luce che c'è sempre una
via d'uscita e
e che non serve a niente veramente
chiudersi perché vedete bisogna
aggrapparsi a questa vita perché
nonostante il dolore nonostante i
patimenti che si possono provare la vita
è meravigliosa sempre e vale la pena
sempre di essere vissuta grazie
[Applauso]